[Musique]
chaque jour ici les paroles
disparaissent sorte d'emballage perdu
mais ses premiers cris représente
pourtant le murmurer la pensée confuse
d'une ville qui n'est
moi j'aime beaucoup les tours à
manhattan tu aime beaucoup les tours du
fond de celle de la défendre j'aime
beaucoup ça comme architecture même
mélangés à des immeubles plus anciens je
trouve pas que ça c'est remettre le
paysage c'est quand même très agréable
surtout quand on est assez haut c'est
vraiment un point de vue mais soyons
justes c'était sordide le quartier où il
y avait la tour autrefois je vous
garantis que c'est l'expression mettait
plutôt crasse et le visage et geek on
peut pas construire au xxème siècle
comme on construisait au moyen-age on
est bien obligés d'employer les
matériaux qui sont d'actualité on n'y
arrivera jamais qu'est ce que tu veux
bien vu ce que nous a répondu la femme
l'autre jour
briard gains pour les chiens c'est
toujours pareil pour dépenser pour
acheter des conneries pour acheter ce
qui me plaît à moi dans ce qui plaît aux
autres parce que la plupart des cas ce
projet des voisins est gosse dans les
ascenseurs c'est encore un travail
brice tougas tous les boutons ça fait
déjà deux fois qu'on remplace les
boutons qui adore cette aventure de
cochon qui m'ont fait payer moins de
mauvais cadeau parce que moi j'avais
mieux quand même mon pilote du quartier
d'avant ou vraiment se connaissaient on
était un peu sonné deux ans si par
malheur le frottant tire sa cigarette
c'est une torche vivante dans
l'ascenseur et ça sera la faute at
il dit chacun fait ce qu'il veut là les
collectivités moi c'est pas sa vie on
peut pas s'acheter n'importe quoi
maintenant rihanna est vachement
n'importe quoi c'est pour ça que la
plupart des gens qui sont en prison si
c'est tous des ouvriers on verra jamais
un avocat emprisonné censeurs là pour
toi qui s'estiment dans un ascenseur
marie se sent bien dans la mesure où il
parle le matin 8 heures ils rentrent le
soir à sept heures il ne vient ici en
fait que pour voir ses enfants - j'ai
couché quelques fois aux
choses comme des loups les gosses les
enfants fortement il m'est même arrivé
et de bloquer l'ascenseur avec une dame
un étage pour finir la conversation un
cahier d'écolier et faire monter ce
projet
cinquantaine
par terre sur la date et on n'arrive pas
à éduquer les gens sont tous même la
caisse qu'il qu'est ce qu'ils font les
parents dans la zone joue à mon père
elle est tout à fait d'accord avec moi
il est laisse faire y a pas d'autorité
il n'y a pas plus ça va et plus ça ira
plus ça se regarde ce qui se veut pas
monter bike ne peut rien faire
maintenant à ces points comme avant
avant les jeunes ils scandaient laguiole
il leur en fallait pas beaucoup pour se
marrer maintenant même avec tout ce
qu'on a on arrive encore à s'emmerder
aujourd'hui c'est ça je suis pas folle
du soleil moi j'aime la vigne même l'eau
thème l'automne et le printemps et puis
j'aime la vie en ville c'est très loin
de ce que je m'imaginais façon il ya
toujours un moment dans la vie où on
trouve quelque chose à faire sinon on et
charteau dans le métro moi j'ai décidé
de revenir travailler sur paris
c'est quand même plus facile non le tour
c'est pas intéressant pas du tout a pour
nous c'est à dire nous les personnes
âgées les retraités peut-être pour les
jeunes a fini rue jeanne-d'arc prolongé
depuis saint quentin je monte plusieurs
fois par jour mais six étages et bien je
vous garantis que je serai bien contente
d'habiter une tour et de ne pas monter à
pied je suis revenu
à paris avec un frigo et sept membres
c'est pas un mobilier 0 ah ben moi je
trouve que c'est beaucoup mieux il a pu
cesser espèce de tous dit qu'il y avait
avant je vous que c'est comme très
agréable de se dire qu'à moins de cinq
minutes de chez soi on peut aller faire
de la poterie du tissage ou la peinture
sur soie ou vous d'autres choses je te
veux pas 20 courses de trois enfants
utilisent laisse même les possibilités
qui sont offertes ici mais enfin c'est
toujours agréable de savoir qu'on peut
le faire
dans un endroit assez petit au plus dix
modes pour le reste moi j'ai eu un
frigidaire
voyons quelle année c'est en 1950 parce
qu'il voit les dégâts et des blousons
noirs wayside toute la merde tout ça
pendant qu'on va dans un café il ya les
personnes qui voyaient en eux des
blousons noirs tout de suite c'est des
voyous c'est des bons à rien ils
travaillent pas sont au chômage il est
évident que n'importe où dans le monde
des premiers coups de téléphone entre
une opération et son inauguration quand
elle fait une taille moyenne c'est un
minimum de dix ans en dix ans
l'économie d'un pays l'économie mondiale
les besoins les idées tout ça a
tellement changé que vous dites souvent
que soient finis à la con vous êtes
trompés comme c'est idiot mais bien sûr
c'est évident alors on modifie
d'ailleurs pendant le tir de ce temps à
partir d'un du tiers du temps au bout de
trois ans quatre ans est figé faut le
faire je construis avec de la pierre je
construis avec de l'argent pour des
hommes je construis quand même avec les
choses qui peuvent se faire je pourrais
faire n'importe quoi je ne serai plus
quoi faire du tout c'est pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui envie de coucher les
tours de mètres au dessus des fenêtres à
la française que j'estime que c'est ce
qu'il faut faire pour demain je ne suis
pas un rêveur je fais pas des utopies et
les grandes surfaces des espaces verts
ben non il y en a pas et ça n'est pas
urbain la ville n'est pas destiné à être
alespo vers le propre d'un architecte
c'est d'essayer de rendre des gens
heureux c'est pas seulement essayé de
loin d'une maison soli c'est que les
gens disent polio 6e des cubes de béton
avec un malheureux qui mètres cubes de
terre c'est dommage on a gâché
surtout pas que je construise un
bâtiment ou moi j'aimerais habiter parce
que nous sommes en tant qu'artiste n'ya
sociale etc m'enfin on mène une vie
normale je ne peux pas me consulte et
moi même comme modèle d'habitants
10 30 euros
je crois que les trois tours d'athènes
mexico et sapporo au niveau de
l'esthétique elles sont jolies mais
c'est pas habitat traite de bobby ogolla
habile g fonctionnement sont devenus
tellement complexe que dans ces
quartiers verticaux comme on y intégrer
en effet au-dessus l'habitation à peu
près au milieu le travail au ras du sol
le commerce en dessous les parkings et
en dessous en fout encore toute la
tripaille l'imbrication de ces réseaux
l'imbrication de ses fonctions en
circulation verticale en face aux
circulations horizontales en fluide et
en réseau il est bien évident qu'un
ensemble comme celui ci va c'est un peu
comparable en effet à la complexité d'un
porte avions d'ailleurs il ya impose de
commandes d'un niveau de cette taille là
autrefois et un immeuble un concierge
eux maintenant ici et un poste de
commande avec des tableaux avec de
télévision avec des choses qui
s'allument de toutes les couleurs
bonsoir exactement sur la passerelle de
commandement d'un bateau ben tu regardes
les pressions le départ aux chaudes
parce que j'ai une place d'athènes un
manque d'eau chaude la beauté pour moi
elle est là elle naît de la contrainte
dieu merci je pense que ça fonctionne
bien je pense que les gens qui sont
dedans si on voit parfaitement content
parce qu'il reste évidemment
d'inconvénients ils sont moins mal
qu'ailleurs on a amélioré la vie urbaine
dans ces quartiers par rapport à la vie
traditionnelle de paris
pour venir ici
c'est une réalisation urbaine de type
capital faut pas se tromper s'épanouit
urbanis universel puisqu'ils alors là
est peut-être alors à mettre en cause
mais pour le problème de paris je pense
qu'on est arrivé à quelque chose
[Musique]
ça fait quatre ans que j'habite ici
j'habite dans cette tour là
avant j'habitais dans un quartier urbain
au milieu au centre de paris ce n'est
pas ta vie
[Applaudissements]
je suis passé d'une vie d'étudiante à
une vie de mère famille nombreuse qu'est
ce que ça voulait dire la vie d'étudiant
on se voulait dire beaucoup de liberté
beaucoup de sorties
une indépendance totale j'avais envie de
me marier
et partant de là au mari mon futur mari
et moi nous avons cherché dans paris un
appartement
de tous les appartements nous avons
visité
de tous les prix qu'on a pu revoir sur
le journal c'est ici que c'était le plus
avantageux en plus intéressant ils sont
bas et tout le monde tous les ouvriers
travaillaient pouvais pas dormir
non ciblage ont bien voulu éviter
peut-être pas j'aime mieux j'aime mieux
qu'au début parce qu'on a exercé le
métier de pharmacien au point
généralement aux pharmacies qui existe
déjà donc vous rentrez dans un costume
qui ne vous appartiennent pas en somme
et là c'était quelque chose de
merveilleux de pouvoir dessiner vous
même un peu pas les plans de votre
pharmacie ou du candeur taille et dans
un complexe qui mêlaient toutes couches
sociales d'une part tous les commerces
qui étaient rassemblés autour de vous
c'était quelque chose qui s'annonçait
comme merveilleux qui disait avoir des
enfants
quand on a acheté ici on nous promettait
des équipements collectifs une vie
sportive
une vie de loisirs enfin la vie idéale
qui est en fin de compte n'allez pas du
tout mais province et en province la vie
on se connaît déjà plus pour la bonne
raison que les ensembles sont bien plus
petit
et puis il ya peut-être plus de chaleur
ya peut-être plus envie de vielles lâché
au premier étage alors en somme cuillé
assez près d'eux je suis assez près
quand même de du public je peux mettre à
la fenêtre je peux être un geek comme
vous êtes là où tu m'aimes vous voyez
les gens comme ça on se retrouve
rassemblés dans des immeubles depuis
pour ce qu'on n'est pas donc c'est de
l'anonymat à pure oui je suis un père
célibataire un père célibataire avec
beaucoup de problèmes et pour les
réseaux de me voir comme j'étais
anciennement parisien ne veut vivre
malgré tout en province j'ai décidé de
m'arrêter de redémarrer sur paris et
vous êtes arrivé à paris bonjour avec
combien d'enfants je suis revenu avec un
frigo et cet enfant
sans travail je ne pouvais pas avoir
d'appartement j'ai dû rester deux mois
de suite dans une place pour pouvoir
donner une feuille de paye d'un mois est
devenu la référence à cette maison bon
j'ai fait un extra de deux mois donc
dans le xiiie et en fonction de cet
employeur que j'ai donné je me suis
trouvée par htc
et puis après j'ai pu
non kazem les enfants dans les
différentes écoles le problème principal
c'est que devrait arriver à faire
comprendre nos administrations des
personnes ça existe il des personnes
avec des enfants le premier va voir
douze ans et la dernière
lors de 17 18 mois c'est comme ça je
sais j'ai mis les âges mais ce que vous
avez droit aux à différents types
d'allocations dettes familiales et j'ai
droit mais enfin
y a rien de fait encore pour dire qu en
quelque sorte je suis une mère au foyer
ces salles elle atteint lundi on sait
pas 17h45 très vite on prépare les pis
pour les jumelles ensuite mon mari
réveil elle est née parce qu'elle est
très longue à se réveiller avait pas se
coucher le soir est très longue à se
lever le matin alors on doit de chacun
un biberon je me dépêche ensuite de
changer les jumelles de les habiller
pendant qu'il a hélas bis lé les vallées
n'est qu'à deux ans et puis bon bah très
très vite on conduire on prend là le
landau l'ascenseur on se précipite à la
crèche à quelle heure
on est généralement à cette heure entre
7 heures et 7 heures et quart et puis on
dépose et je mets mon nez des habits on
leur remet les vêtements de la crèche
ben ali on va même jusqu'à les pousser à
lima ont les bons les couches les
embrasse et je conduis l'aîné chez sa
nourrice et puis de là je repars d'un
travail je cavale c'est à dire qu'une
journée par exemple je démarre à 18h45
je les lèvres j'ai petit déjeuner tous à
8h30 ils sont à l'école 1 8h30 à l'école
après c'est moi qui pars je ne sais
qu'en général je reviens ici
jusqu'à vers 9h où je fais ce qui est à
faire derrière dans la maison 9 heures
après bon ben j'ai je m'arrange toujours
pour reprendre deux premiers rendez vous
10 heures
et les enfants sont à l'école de je vais
fait manger à la cantine
il reste à l'étude donc jusqu'à jusqu'à
6 heures je peux travailler jusqu'à 6h
dans l'immédiat j'ai réussi à trouver
une étudiante qui vient que l'ema sur
deux heures le temps de la deuxième
journée hier deux soirs à partir de 6
heures ce qui fait que ça me prolonge la
journée travail jusqu'à 8 heures vous
faites la cuisine fait le ménage ou
la tendance où jai ho chi minh et la rue
jeanne d'arc prolonger c'était une belle
maison tout de même en pierre de taille
un 5 pièces mais il ya les pattes salle
de bain et puis il n'y avait pas de
chauffage central on avait juste une
salamandre pour chauffer tout
l'appartement
après je me suis installé rue d'amen
donc j'avais quand même le confort et
j'avais même un jardin de la rue de ruud
a même
vieillard disait tout attendri
paris vous l'appelez paname mec alors
regretter ce pari c'était paris au
port tellement fort tellement je trouve
que je vais mieux maintenant que
les gens disent toujours le contraire je
trouve que envie mieux on vit mieux
maintenant que lorsque j'avais 20 ans
qu'est ce qui a changé
je sais pas les loisirs tout on sort
gala télévision il ya beaucoup de choses
quand même maintenant aller personne ici
et de s'emmerder
théorie pour ya rien pour non plus
rien du tout pour les personnes ici ici
il ya des logements c'est tout le reste
ils s'en foutent
on va lui tu verras sur moi que
ceci était une guerre à charbon de 7
hectares sur lequel il y avait trois
wagons
2 top charbon et une dizaine de
personnes qui travaillaient est bien
évident que c'était un terrain mal
employé alors l'intérieur du plan italie
on a prévu là dedans la densité normal
parisienne avec les clips des
habitations et des bureaux en là dessus
il ya 2500 logements en
un bouquet de trois tours un bouquet de
tours elles n'ont pas toutes été fait
d'ailleurs parce que comme il ya eu un
changement de politique au sujet des
tours à cette partie de l'îlot ne sera
pas terminé de la même manière ça s'est
fait relativement très vite ça s'est
fait relativement très vite font une
tour comme ça on la pousse en un an un
an l'essentiel de la tourelle est faite
il ya le remplissage qui prend encore 1
an mais ça va ça va très très vite ça a
été fait cette opération là étaient
faits en moins de six ans ce qui pour
paris très rapide et pour un ensemble
d'une taille très rapide alors on a
gardé avec tout le reste
les équipements qui a les écoles et les
maternelles ont ces mêmes pays des
sculptures et des peintures là dessus il
ya eu il ya une vie il ya une vie sur
cette dalle dans cet axe là il ya une
rue nord-sud parce que le soleil est en
gros ici le soleil c'était le sud étant
là le soleil se déplace comme ça et on a
à peu près toujours cette rue centrale
qui est animé qui est éclairé toute la
journée et
kiffer sentent de petits leaders c'est
une c'est une ville
une ville dans la ville dont les
premiers habitants ne savent pas encore
s'ils sont pionniers ou victimes alors
ils se débattent se reconnaissent et se
regroupent
ce combat c'est déjà leur première
histoire
de la même façon beaucoup de gens disent
bien un bateau c'est une grande ville
flottante on a résonné à linverse on a
dix sept grandes villes elle flotte pas
mais ça ressemble quand même drôlement
un bateau et peut-être camarades en
ferait la sphère alors
se syndiquer donc allé au ministère de
la marine puis il a demandé s'ils
avaient pas quelqu'un qui s'en allait à
ce moment là qu'ils souhaiteraient
travailler dans cet ensemble et puis au
même moment moi je quittais la marine
une dizaine d'années de service pour des
raisons personnelles je sentais bien que
j'allais être confronté avec toutes
sortes de deux problèmes de la vie
civile que je le connaissais mal et
qu'ils m'aideraient à mieux la connaître
et que d'un autre côté sur le plan
technique j'avais largement de quoi nous
contenter puisque ça correspondait à peu
près à ce que je savais faire ce qu'on
avait appris auparavant donc le plancher
picturale je suis plutôt positif est
satisfait sur le plan personnel c'est
une expérience et une grande expérience
je terminerai cette opération avec de
nouveaux amis et quelques ennemis sur le
plan financier c'est une très mauvaise
opération
espèces elles pèsent lourdement sur les
fonds de notre société franchement c'est
une mauvaise opération très mauvaise
opération nous l'avons mené jusqu'à
jusqu'au bout et il y a dix ans nous ne
pouvions pas connaître le rythme de
commercialisation des tours à paris dans
le xiiie arrondissement nous ne pouvions
pas supposer qu'il y aurait plusieurs
tours à la vente en même temps sur le
13ème arrondissement
et comme une tour en plusieurs années à
construire qu'on ne peut pas la freiner
parallèlement ils cassent 5 10 tours
concomitamment sur le marché dans le
xiiième d'où un taux d'écoulement très
bas tout est difficultés financières
pour nous nous avons été quasiment
jusqu'au bout nous irons jusqu'au bout
mais le plan financier est tout à fait
négatifs on avance on l'a trop pressé
parmi les touristes partent tout autour
absente dans des cages
partout en garde on voit des auteurs tu
penses c'est se battre au truc à part ça
c'est le vieux paris ces thèmes avec des
petits immeubles
sont dans le béton dans le béton c'est
pourri moi je me plais ici parce que ya
mes copains il y aura pas mes copains
c'est mort quand on habite dans un petit
immeuble bomba à part la concierge la
personne qui nous fait chier on est dans
la rue on est tout de suite dehors tu
est ici il ya le pc il ya les flics
jaillit à tout le monde aussitôt qu'on
fait une connerie tout de suite on se
rattrape et moi j'aime pas ça les gens
qui viennent vivre ici il trouve un
outil trouve un ensemble pré fabriqués
et puis ensuite ils s'en servent à leur
manière qui n'est peut-être pas du tout
la manière qu'avait prévu l'architecte
urbaniste où les gens qui ont voulu cet
ensemble il aura fallu deux ou trois
années pour que les gens commencent à se
rencontrer à constituer des petites
associations des groupes de travail soit
pour descendre dans intérêts soit pour
mieux s'occuper de leurs enfants on peut
pas avec la meilleure volonté du monde
recréé une ville avec tout ce que ça
comporte 2 ans dont 6 mois ou en quatre
ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais m
[Applaudissements]
départ tout le monde pour dans son petit
coin on voudrait peut-être faire quelque
chose on n'ose pas faut toujours un bouc
émissaire enfin quelque chose en à
fonder enfin une amicale dans la couture
à côté ça m'a permis de rencontrer
beaucoup de champ est vraiment de faire
de faire des amis puis d'avoir
d'excellentes relations avec beaucoup de
personnes non au départ c'est surtout
des problèmes de des problèmes d'habitat
simple soit il ya des films
2d wauquiez qui sont qui sont mal posé
on c'est un problème de défense quoi
et puis après il ya eu d'autres
problèmes des problèmes de d'ensemble
réglemente assurant des problèmes de
sécurité
problème de manque d'équipement
manque de locaux sociaux d'activité
évidemment et tout ça bon ben on est
arrivé une
super association une association qui à
la fois défend est il organisé ces
derniers dans les mêmes quartiers il
s'est donné une vie en train je pense
qu'il ya des gens qui qui de toute
manière on va malgré tout les
possibilités de rencontres sur la dalle
de rencontres dans le hall de la tour
dans les ascenseurs et des chants qui se
dérange non pas pour participer à aucune
activité ça je crois qu'il ya une
question de caractère mais on se sent
quand même pas tellement isolé déjà avec
le avec le niveau de vie de l'heure
actuelle si on était tous en train de se
battre si on était tous en train de
se débiner ça marche réponse à ça va
marcher
heureusement qu'ils allaient y a des
gens quand même si bon bah qu'ils sont
copains qui sont simples et tout parce
que si avec les
six avec les commerciaux qui était qui
étaient étaient pourris qui était pour
itunes et puis tout ça ça et ça y répond
moi j'ai pris l'habitude quand je rentre
dans l'âge de l'ascenseur je dis bonjour
on me répond pas toujours mais ça fait
regard j'ai dû quand même bon jour où il
dit au revoir quand je sors de
l'ascenseur vous le faites un peu exprès
pour que je le fais un petit peu alors
ça commence à venir il suffit de il
suffit de commencer voilà là pour les
fêtes de noël j'ai accroché à ma porte
j'ai accroché duo puis j'ai mes marques
et meilleurs voeux à bagua quand même
quelqu'un qui avec a écrit en dessous
merci voyez c'est vrai palier enfin on
voit les gens que si on a envie de les
voir monde subit pas tellement la
présence des voisins des fois on se rend
compte au vide ordures et puis à leurs
bonbons bonjour bonsoir et puis voilà
c'est tout j'avais tord à thème
au 10e étage j'ai beaucoup d'amis klein
on voit ces deux là j'en ai cinq mille
ha et à la perte la fin d'où est-ce que
tu es venu avant
au jour où j'habitais avant le liban
nous avons des
cambodgiens
dans un coin je crois que c'est des
brésiliens alors là on les voit jamais
on voit que les gosses et encore les
négoces en on les voit pas souvent il ya
pas mal d'étrangers oui est ce que ça
vous paraît à moi je viens moi j'aime
beaucoup comment c'est parce que ce mot
police étaient des souvenirs des
calculateurs mais par contre je trouve
que au niveau des classes d'âge
c'est très homogène il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ont à peu près notre h coup de
jeune de jeunes ménages avec d'ailleurs
une sorte d'explosion démographique
je suis sûr que entre printemps et l'été
dernier est né au moins à deux enfants
par étage
[Musique]
et un certain nombre de personnes qui
m'ont proposé si vous avez un problème
je peux vous aider à garder vos enfants
si vous voulez sortir j'ai trouvé ça
assez sympathique j'ai pensé que ça
c'était quand même liée à ce phénomène
de tournon essentiellement les contacts
se font à travers des enfants
sa tendance à devenir un petit peu un
village c'est certain mais ça n'a pas
été évident au départ car il y avait une
sorte de ségrégation qui se faisait
entre les différents habitants en
découlent malheureusement et à la
ségrégation sociale qu'elle se fait
elle se fait mais très doucement mais
elle se fait par exemple les mecs de
rome ils vont pas tellement avec les
mecs de kovalev mais avec les tours des
grands tours athènes on est chacun dans
le tout compte fait c'est comme ça on
cherche pas à connaître l'autre vous
êtes raciste presque non quand même pas
combien lassitude dit toi tu es de roms
alors t'es pas du tout non on se connaît
on se parle même je connais beaucoup
quand même de ce que valait seulement il
va il préfère se taire en trop nous
aussi les vieux ils sont chacun un
recoin mais déjà ils se rassemblent les
vieux c'est chacun pour soi way le
voisin regarde le ca c'est ce que j'aime
pas aussi dans les hlm par exemple c'est
la mentalité des gens oui ils sont
toujours en train de se bouffer nez ils
essaient de se faire des vacheries entre
entre voisins tant qu'historienne du
mois comment ces étudiants ton histoire
j'ai
faim je sens assez facilement les
problèmes de vie en communauté et toute
la manière dont la vie communautaire par
exemple dans les dans les villages à
puisse détruire avec la disparition des
fêtes avec la disparition de tas de
systèmes d'être collective donc prête et
c est comment les gens soient absolument
déracinés en ville mais après tout on
pourrait essayer de retrouver recréer
d'autres structures dans lesquelles les
gens se retrouvent leur forme d'autres
communautés le béton
c'est une forêt ça donne une sensation
de malaise
d'étouffement d'écrasement
qui est très désagréable et très
oppressante
j'ai l'impression d'être comme une
fourmi
il n'ya pas les bruits d'oiseaux il n'y
a pas de la route ya pas les harpies
rien n'y a rien il ya le béton cet
univers de béton je pense est
supportable je connais beaucoup de
personnes dont des spécialistes
architecture d'urbanité sociologue qui
habite cette cité qui sont satisfaits de
leur sort comme habitant univers de
béton regarder n'importe quelle rue de
2,2 passes il ya déjà 10 à 100 ans qui
est univers de pierres noires mais cet
essai et enfin je suis certain que c'est
dix fois pire encore la comparaison elle
est entre les deux elle est pas entre
aller vivre à la campagne aller vite
dans les tours mon problème est un
quartier de paris et bien pour un
quartier de paris je pense que par
rapport à ceux qui sont fait auparavant
on a fait ce qu'on a pu pour que ce soit
plus vivant plus multiple plus plus
riches et le béton ou la pierre ou la
vieille pierre noire ce propos l'un que
l'autre
que répondre rien probablement et
pourtant la riposte est déjà venu le
nombre particulièrement impressionnant
d'animaux de toutes natures c'est ainsi
que la vie se charge de malmener ceux
qui tentent de l'étouffer
[Musique]
le matin la kachin qu aller propres et à
pau me dis oh là où tout seul y'a plein
de papiers partout ya vingt-six de
chiens et puis on peut rien faire
et puis les plaintes ne pousse pas parce
que la déchetterie dessus
il ya des jeunes mettent des papilles
dans les bassins
alors on peut plus faire en rien on n'a
aucun contact humain on est environné
tour c'est à peine si on peut
reconnaître ou sur sa porte les gens
viennent vous voir céder numéro nous
sommes au numéro tallieu on ne connaît
pas me matas mattel une ancienne numéro
hôtels et les gens tournent vraiment
dans un tour de babel des temps vous
savez on ne se reconnaît pas
beaucoup de ces gens égarés nous arrive
nous arrive après une ou deux heures de
recherches de 10 ans et enfin dites moi
comment je peux trouver untel ou untel
rsa sur les aiguilles mais c'est pas
raisonnable il sait pas c'est pas
fonctionnels ces gens là devraient
pouvoir trouver leur chemin tout seul
tous les services y sont privés on paye
pour tout la surveillance le nettoyage
l'enlèvement des ordures donc le service
sécurité par exemple même la police n'a
pas le droit d'intervenir n'importe où
n'importe comment
ça pose même d'assez gros problème on a
deux problèmes de sécurité dans
l'ensemble par exemple des le
stationnement des voitures ont bas
empêcherait quasiment les pompiers
d'intervenir c'est quand même assez
inquiétant
non il est bien certain qu'à certaines
heures il vaut mieux pas se promener
tout seul dans les parkings fait il
m'est arrivé d'avoir très peur ou et
pourtant je ne suis pas particulièrement
effrayé demain je me suis promené
longtemps avec à siffler c'est ce que
conseille la services de sécurité et des
enfants qui auraient été agressées mon
des phénomènes
d'exhibitionnisme
c'est quand même un an sans vous il ya
plus de dix mille habitants si tu as un
lieu de passage aussi toute la publicité
de ce centre avait été conçue d'ailleurs
fort intelligemment sur le côté loisir
qui était du reste hagen et la base tout
le support publicitaire de cette action
et donc les gens à acheter les commerces
d'autres appartements d'autres sont rués
en location beaucoup surtout parce qu'on
leur promettait un centre de sport avec
une piscine avec des patinoires à ta
chose qu'on n'a pas normalement ni dans
une vigne dans un village il s'était
donc quelque chose d'assez
extraordinaire on nous promettait une
vie idéale
avec équipements collectifs crèches
maternelles centre sportif
des commerces est très proche ça c'était
le rêve il ya peut-être eu un concours
de circonstances qui a fait qu'à partir
du moment où les commerçants ont
entrepris une action en justice
pour la réalisation d'une part des
crèches des écoles et également de sa
gamme que l'on a vu naître ce stadium et
encore il y avait encore loin du rêve à
la réalité il ya une piscine qui fait 14
mètres sur 10 il y a les patinoires est
en plastique enfin c'est réellement un
rêve qui n'est pas un cauchemar et qu'il
pour nous a été trop longue notre agence
de publicité avait prévu dans ces
dépliants
description très très large des
activités qui serait possible de faire
lorsque nous sommes arrivés au stade de
la réalisation de ce complexe sports et
loisirs qui appartient encore au
constructeur nous avons essayé de
redéfinir le plus intelligemment
possible
outil au service de tous
une réduction n'ont même pas une
réduction un choix de piscine d'une
taille raisonnable est suffisante pour
les habitants le choix du plastique
contre la glace pour permettre d'avoir
une salle polyvalente qui permet d'un
instant à l'autre de changer de
discipline de fer du fou du basket du
volley ball
le stade c'est un coin chouette pour toi
ouais c'est pas mal malgré qu'il faut
payer peu partout c'est pas mal
qu'est-ce qu'elle vient
il ya déjà d'avoir faim des jeunes sont
plus que nous mais quand même nous
comprenne
vous avez eu un a priori c'est et
construire verticalement pour pouvoir
libérer un espace qui à l'heure actuelle
est un espace à fonctionnel bon il n'y a
pas d' espaces verts il n'ya pas de dieu
pour que les enfants par exemple parce
que j'intéresse aux enfants puissent
jouer en toute sécurité et surtout à des
jeux qui les intéresse bon autre que de
faire la nique aux gardiens on nous
avait promis des arbres il y à 3 ap dans
un bar contraste d'un magasin il ya
environ quatre à cinq mille mètres
carrés des espaces verts qui sont
répartis question morcelé en quatre
cents et quelques bacs à terre en
jardinière les plantes souffrent elles
demandent plus de soin d'arrosage etc et
en plus on les voit pas on n'a vraiment
pas l'impression longtemps chez nous qui
a un demi hectare de plantation et une
absence 10 passes faire d'abord c'est
quand même très sec
je crois qu'il vaut mieux effectivement
pas parler des espaces verdalle parce
que bien sûr à peu près ce sont des
périodes une petite tache de couleur de
l'or de la décoration est pas du tout de
l'ordre de la vie végétale saint derrien
d'accord mais est ce que vous connaissez
les besoins de l'enfant par rapport à
ses possibilités de jouer et patinent et
ramper faire de la bicyclette taper dans
un ballon assez terreur pendant le
banquet rocco vous pensé ou dit les
plaines d'avant
d'abord moi j'ai mes gamins à paris j'ai
bien connu cette vie de quartier de
gamins à paris qui consistait d'ailleurs
surtout à sa tante d'un porche à l'autre
pour se battent à coups de cartables
puis d'explorer les maisons en
construction en ruine c'est ça le
terrain aventures d'un parisien et je
crois que ce qu'on a fait ici c'est de
leur donner plus d'espoir c'est une
variété que le trottoir entre une façade
et un alignement de voitures en
stationnement bien sûr ça n'est pas le
terrain d'aventuré idéal mais c'est la
ville dès qu'il y ait du vent
explications de m des enfants sur la
dalle ne fût ce que parce que ma
consultation de pédiatrie serez plein de
titres et il ya vraiment plus d'otites
ici qu'ailleurs je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas du tout je sais que si
effectivement vous laisser des enfants
sur votre dalle vente et effectivement
on va avoir beaucoup de travail les
enfants sont les maîtres mais l'horizon
rien trouvé mieux que de jouer au hockey
avec des boîtes de conserve
issa braz
soulignant là tellement on les ballots
le ballon de football qu'est ce qu'on a
entendu des hurlements
alors l'été là au mois d'août on n'a pas
pu avoir déchu est ouvert alors deux
trois fois quand même on a alerté leurs
la sécurité quand même c'est interdit ce
faire du vélo interdit d'y au foot
interdit de faire du patin à roulettes
focal de faire tout quoi mais comment ça
interdit à bahia un gardien 3 mal quand
ils nous baser l'aubaine il nous dit
descendent ou d'arrêter d'y et si on
continue à jouer nous prend la balle
nous confisquer nos vélos tous mais
pourquoi parce que il ya trop de monde
sur la dalle déjà ou quoi c'est interdit
c'est pas tout ça ternit pas non à
nouveau je le state interview fille
[Musique]
le vrai problème c'est qu'effectivement
ce serait des espaces non rentables et à
partir du moment où ces espaces ne
serait pas rentable je ne vois pas quel
promoteur aurait permis que l'on fasse
une et on structure dans ce vertical des
espaces horizontaux qui puisse être
accessible à tous et certains protégés
pour les enfants nombre de critiques
venant maintenant que l'opération est
très difficile à terminer
ne sont pas très très constructive pour
oui bah mon métier c'est pas de jouer à
plus fou de toi hein parce que c'était
déjà bien assez fou d'avoir fait ça et
de l'avoir pensé il ya 15 ans et c'est
déjà maintenant c'est déjà par rapport
aux autres parisiens par rapport à
n'importe quel autre quartier c'est déjà
un espace un peu fou alors plus fou que
moi qu'est ce qui vous paraît le plus
injuste d'être considéré comme le seul
responsable non pas moi même mais sous
le terme promoteurs que notre compagnie
soit considéré comme le seul responsable
de l'opération alors que l'on fait
travailler de nombreux prestataires qui
ont chacun de leur part de
responsabilité pour les bonnes choses et
les moins bonnes choses je me dis
pourquoi dans l'ensemble de ses
utilisateurs ne participe-t-il pas à
l'élaboration de ce type de ville or il
existe des groupements de plus en plus
nombreux maintenant est de plus en plus
fréquent de d'utilisateurs qui ont leur
mot à dire et qui veulent dire un mot or
politiquement ces gens là ne peuvent pas
dire leur mot et c'est ça qui le mange
l'habitant futur de ce que je vais faire
il existe pas il n'existe pas je verrai
pour les raisons assez simple par
exemple ne serait ce que le jeu ne sais
pas quand je vais construire à quel prix
ça va être tout est vendu quand ça va
sortir eh bien il se peut que toute une
classe de population qu'on est prévue
qui sera qui habitent là dedans et
puissent plus où elle puisse de nouveau
nom même au niveau de la catégorie
sociale des individus jeunes jeu c'est
approximativement mais mal qui va
habiter là dedans c'est pour ça que je
dis l'habitant de ce que je fais il
n'existe pas
[Musique]
et pourtant ils sont là vivent multiples
et d'autres viendront et attendront
aussi malgré qu'on les nids cette ville
idéale ou simplement même un outil à
vivre mieux
est ce qu'il ya un décalage entre
l'utopie le rêve et la réalité qu'est ce
qui s'est passé
c'est une question
d'éducation qu'on peut poser pour tous
les grands problèmes actuels alors quand
la nuit efface toute querelle vient le
temps où la paix est le rêve peuvent
guérir et redonner la ferveur de
l'enfant
il faudra bien un jour assumer le
modernisme et laisser parler nos vrais
rêves sans vous
je vois
[Musique]
quelque chose pour les jeunes parce que
vraiment on s'emmerde
[Musique]